Hello, hello, hi Drew.
I love people who are like you know,
they seem green and crunchy on one level
but they're like smart and know how to get it done
on the other level, that's my favorite kind of polarity,
I'm not gonna lie, so I'm so happy
to see you today Danny.
Well thank you and I'm glad that we get
to come together now, for the first time,
which is really exciting.
I know, last time I was like gluing bird houses absurdly.
I remember.
But there are so many things I want to do with you,
so let's continue this.
Okay, Naturally Delicious Deserts
is your second cookbook
and it's dedicated to living healthy
while indulging, which this is something
that really speaks to me, because when I indulge,
I go this way and when I deprive,
I just get sad and then I bounce to the other side,
it's like too much extremes
and so what you're presenting here really speaks to me.
Lots of super foods, lots of low sugar,
lots of alternatives, without depriving yourself.
And by the way, I don't know if this
is a good segway or not, I also bought
my cookbook club selection for you too,
before we get to my book.
This is the Vegenaise cookbook.
I don't know if you're familiar
with the vegan mayo Veganaise.
I guess that wouldn't be me dipping my crackers in it,
like straight into the jar the other night,
standing up in my kitchen.
I am not only a Veganaise fan, I am an OG-er.
I think I've been using it
since like they came onto the scene and I was so excited.
I've been pouring through this book
over the holidays and I'm so glad
you brought it to cookbook club.
You really get me and this is an incredible product
and I love the cookbook so thank you
for bringing it to the club.
I mean the chocolate cake is insane
but we're here to talk about my book too
and what we're gonna make today Drew,
is a sticky toffee baked oatmeal.
So we know oatmeal is good for you
because it's very filling, it's got lots of vitamins
and minerals, but you can bake it
and actually do like a sticky toffee pudding coating on top,
so it's a little extra sweet, but we're gonna use
a different type of sugar, we're gonna use
coconut sugar and coconut milk,
to make that beautiful caramelized toffee on top.
I am so excited, let's do this.
Okay, so what we wanna do,
is that in our cooked oatmeal, we have four cups
of rolled oats and four cups of water
that we cook together and what we wanna add
to this, is flax seeds.
So what I love about flax seeds,
is that this is something you can use,
fresh flax seeds or whole flax seeds.
We're adding a jar of oatmeal
because it's gonna help really bind it even more
and add more nutrition to your oatmeal.
Flax seed is really good for digestion
and movement and they have so many benefits.
It's so good for you but also,
a lot of people don't know what to do with it
or you don't wanna eat it by itself
because it's kind difficult to digest that way
and in oatmeal, you can hide it in there
and nobody knows about it.
So after we do this, this is sort of our base.
What we're gonna do next, is we're gonna talk about
this beautiful sticky toffee.
So it's two cans, I'm gonna tilt this as much as I can.
I know, me too.
But it's two cans of coconut milk
and it's about, how much sugar?
And it's also a cup of coconut sugar.
And you simmer this and you keep simmering it
and simmering it, until you get this
like beautiful, caramelized consistency right there.
What does yours look like Danny?
Is it viscus, is it mellifluous, is it sticky,
what am I working with here?
You have a beautiful consistency,
I like to keep it just a little bit more,
like a more liquid kinda consistency.
Okay.
'cause when it cools down it thickens up.
Look what happened to my liquidy,
viscous, mellifluous sauce over the break,
it congealed and it's ready to go.
So Drew, after you bake your oatmeal in the oven
at 350 degrees, they come out
in beautiful squares like this, do you see those?
Yes I see it.
It's almost like a big, cakey consistency
and so if you just pour this on a plate,
what you do to finish it off after you bake it,
is that you pour some of the caramel.
And you bake it at 350, but for how long?
About 20, to 25 minutes.
Pour the caramel on top,
take a little bit of the chopped pecans.
Sprinkle those right on top.
Me and Arthur are two kitchen cats right now.
(nibbling)
Oh, that looks really good, that looks really good.
Wow, it's been styled.
I always love to do
when you have something really sweet like this,
a little sprinkle of sea salt.
Yes.
Is also really nice right on top, don't you think?
A little salt and sugar.
May I even dare to say a mardar.
(laughing)
That's a fancy way of doing it
but I definitely approve 100%.
You are A plus Drew.
(screaming)
A plus.
Danny.
That is beautiful, that is really beautiful.
(laughing)
Now, what you have there is not one serving
so because this is a lighten desert book.
Depending on the day, yes.
That's about six servings,
so you wanna just cut them into generous squares
and then you have a beautiful sticky toffee baked oatmeal.
Isn't that gorgeous?
Oh my gosh, oh my gosh.
You know something is good when chewing is irritating
'cause you just wanna get to the next bite Danny.
(laughing)
I mean beauty shot.
All right, here we go.
Oh Danny, this is incredible and so are you.
And this is really cool,
this is where my daughter got excited,
which is that what we like to do together,
is we did the avocado pits, how we die.
We were on the show like why didn't we think
to make guacamole then with the avocados.
So inspired by that, you have a fun tip to make
all of these leftovers and the flax seeds
and we're gonna post it on our website
'cause guess what it makes?
And this is where my daughter's excitement comes in, slime.
So go to our website, check that out.
Danny's gonna take us through it
and we're just gonna keep repurposing
and reliving and enjoying and Danny, thank you so much.
You are just the greatest,
I can't wait to do more and more and more.
Aw thank you Drew, thank you.
Thank you Danny, see you soon.
I'm shocked, I'll take it.
(upbeat music)